buck
tu te souviens de moi ta mère s'appelait
ça tu mettais du papier journal dans tes
chaussures tu est recherché je ne fais
plus à des gens qui pensent le contraire
vont arriver et ils n'ont pas
l'intention de prendre vivant
captain
beaucoup de gens vous considère comme un
héros mais certains préfèrent le mot
justice y est vous vous êtes arrogé des
pouvoirs illimités vous avez agi sans
aucun contrôle
et ça le monde ne peux plus le tolérer
je sais ce que représente pour toi mais
ne s'en mêle pas s'il te plait ça ne
ferait qu'empirer les choses
vous avez l'intention de m'arrêter
il y aura des conséquences captain vous
avez l'air se regarde j'ai eu une
mauvaise journée
si nous n'acceptons pas certaines
limites ne valent pas mieux que les
ennemis c'est pas comme ça que je vois
les choses
j'écrase très bien mon point sur votre
magnifique dentition
bret seulement comme envisage toutes les
possibilités les gens qui te tire dessus
finissent généralement par tirer aussi
sur moi
tu sais ce qui va se passer
tu compte vraiment en tirer à la force
de dépens
qu'est ce qu'on fait
11 pas
puis désolé tony
si j'avais le choix je ferais pas ça
mais c'est mon ami comme je l'étais